Can you speak a little bit more to the connection between aliens
and technology that, uh,
Jack valet had in his own one individual mind,
that's very tempting to kind of separate as two separate
endeavors.
Why did you come to believe that they're one in the same
or at least part of the same, uh,
intellectual journey.
Thanks for asking that again,
because nobody asks me that question and it's
central to my project.
So jock was a huge influence is a huge influence on me.
Um, he taught me a lot. Um, I had,
he gave me access to some of his information that's, um,
that he keeps, um, but a lot of his information is actually there,
out there for everyone to read. Um, he has an academia.edu page and he just,
so he didn't have this, unfortunately,
when I was doing my research in 2012 and 2013,
so I had to go back and do microfish type stuff. You know,
what I did was I began to read everything that he wrote and he actually gave me
a lot of his books too. And he told me you, I remember, um,
he dropped me off from,
this is actually quite interesting if you'll allow me to tell you a little
story. Okay. And it also includes Iowasca so,
Okay. So I was at a conference in, uh, mid, it was a small conference,
um, uh,
very interesting people in California on the Pacific ocean and Jacques was
there. And, um, this is actually I opened my book. This is the book,
this is the I go, I see the preface to my book. I go on this ride.
He takes me through Silicon Valley. I've lived there, right.
My grandparents grew up in the same place that he raised his children in
Belmont. And so, um, but we were there, Robbie Graham,
who's a great Eufaula just in his own. Right. And, um,
and film theorist. I highly recommend his work. Um,
so we were together and he was taking us to San Francisco where I was going to
meet my brother. Who's going to take me home.
And so he took us on this long journey and he talked to us and as we got out of
the car, um,
he gave me several of his books and one in particular, he gave me, he said,
read this first. I was like, okay. I definitely will read that first.
Okay. So this is how the Iowasca figures in. So, um, we were,
I didn't take it nor have I taken it. Okay. So we're at this place and,
um,
in California and Alex Gray and his wife were there and they were talking about,
um, their experiences with psychedelics, you know,
he's an amazing visionary artist. Okay. So he,
he believes that there's a place that you can enter.
And he and his wife would enter this space with either, you know,
Iowasca or LSD or something like that. And they would not talk to each other,
but they would be having the same exact experience. So they would,
it was almost like having the same dream. Right. Okay. So,
so somehow that whole event with Jacques,
their TA and them talking about their experiences in these realms of which
religious studies people are quite familiar by the way,
because visionary experiences are what we study.
So all of this seems super familiar to me, and I recognize that immediately,
that shock that it hit me, like,
you know,
very obvious that UFO's and these experiences and
technology all seemed, they were all meshed together.
And I knew that I had to take them.
I knew I had to read everything shock ever wrote,
and the best stuff he's written by the way is the stuff,
his little essays that he wrote in the 1970s.
And they were peer reviewed essays about the beginning of the internet and how a
lot of it was based on, um, basically like,
um, neural connection with the internet,
like somehow psychic connection through the internet with others and things like
that.
The brain is a biological neural network. There's, uh,
this connection between division neurons and so on.
And that's what ultimately is able to have, uh,
memories and has cognitive ability and is able to, uh,
perceive the world and generate ideas.
And those ideas are then spread on the internet even from the very early
days to other humans.
So it gets injected or travels into the brains of other humans.
And it goes around in there and then spits out all this stuff and it goes back
and forth. So it's, it's nice to think of a network that's in our mind,
individual mind, as, I mean,
I'm very much even deeply connected to the network.
That is the connection between humans through the internet.
And so in that sense, jock saw the internet as this,
as this powerful, um,
as a source of power and wisdom that is beyond our own.
Definitely that's external to us, like a non, like, you know,
if you could call it atonomous AI, right.
It's non-human intelligence in the sense, even though humans are a part of it.
Or we're invaded by it, or, you know, whatever you want to call it.
Yeah. Right. It's the chicken and egg, right.
If I can go on, I don't want to experience, I'm not done with that. Yeah.
So, and this is, so this is where I come to this idea that,
um, we're in this space, we're in now a new space of religion of religiosity.
So what happens is then I,
and it's like a biosphere and I'll talk about that in a minute. So we, so,
so jock takes us back. We get to San Francisco and my brother,
who is your straight lace person, army guy, and everything like that.
Um, I get into his car and the first thing he tells is I took Iowasca and I was
talking and he goes, it's going to save humanity.
That's great. Yeah. As I mentioned to you offline,
I talked to Matthew Johnson is a Hopkins professor on a,
he's a really a scholar of most he's he's.
He started most drugs cause he's also really deeply studied cocaine and all
those stuff on negative effects. And, uh,
he's focused on a lot of positive effects of the different psychedelics.
It's kind of fascinating.
So I'm very much interested in exploring
the science of what these things do to the, to the human mind.
And also personally exploring it, although it's like this weird gray area,
which he he's he's masterful at,
which is he's a professor at John Hopkins,
one of the most prestigious universities in the world and,
and doing large-scale studies of this stuff. And it, until,
until he got a lot of money for these studies, even in, uh,
Hopkins itself, there's not much risk, not even respect. It was like,
uh, people just didn't want to talk about it. Uh, as a,
as a legitimate field of inquiry,
it's kind of fascinating how hesitant we are as a little
human civilization to, um,
legitimize the exploration of the mysterious of whatever the
definition of the mysterious is for that particular period of time.
So for us now there's like little groups of things.
Like I would say consciousness in the space of like computer science
research is something that's still like, Hmm. I don't know.
Maybe it was philosophers kicking around for a little longer.
And then the certainly extraterrestrial life forms
from, um,
in most formulations of that problem space, uh,
is still the other, it's still the source of the mysterious,
except maybe like SETI, which is like,
how can we detect signals from far away alien intelligence is that we'll be able
to, uh, perceive yeah, it's a,
and psychedelics is another one of those that's like, we're starting to see.
Okay. Well, can we, um,
try to see if there's some medical applications of like helping you get,
uh, like he does studies of helping you quit smoking or help you in some kind of
treatment of some disease. And he's sneaking into that. I mean,
it's like openly sneaking into it, some studies on it of like,
how can you expand the mind with these tools and what can the
mind discover through psychedelics and so on?
And we're like slowly creeping into the space of being able to explore these
mysterious questions, but it's like,
it sucks that sometimes a lot of people have to die, meaning,
sorry. Uh, they have to age out
like it's like faculty have a,
and people have a fixed set of ideas and they stick by them.
And in order for new ideas to come in,
then the young folks have to be born with the PA with an open
mind and the possibility of those ideas.
And then they have to become old enough and get A's in school and whatever to,
to, uh, to then carry those ideas forward. So, you know, the acceptance of the,
uh, exploration of the mysterious takes time. It's kinda sad.